we do have i i guess what we're calling
good news regarding the johnson and
johnson vaccine
dr anthony fauci says that he believes
the u.s
is going to resume use of the johnson
and johnson vaccine for coronavirus
by the end of the week maybe with some
kind of warning
or restriction attached you might
remember we covered last tuesday that
regulators said
temporarily pause use of the single dose
johnson and johnson vaccine there were
six
cases of rare brain blood clots
all in women age 18 to 48
i i believe as of right now that one of
those women
died this is out of about 7 million
johnson and johnson vaccine doses that
were given
and dr fauci says he's expecting a
decision on that vaccine maybe by this
friday
and uh that the most likely outcome he
seems confident that there will be a
resumption of the use of that vaccine
you will again remember that this was
within 13 days of receiving the shot
women aged 18 to 48 who developed
these symptoms the fda decided to put a
pause
out of quote an abundance of caution and
unfortunately you know this is one of
those things that
what what's tough about it is that it
will
create certainly some additional
anti-vaxx
sentiment and provide uh fuel for the
anti-vaccine crowd
even if it is not um warranted and
it's one of these things where you
really have to think of the numbers big
picture that vaccine has been given
to more than seven million people there
have been six or seven
blood clots reported uh and
one of those people died and when you
first of all when you compare that to
the death rate of getting the virus
itself that's important context to have
and to provide
the other reality is you know if if you
wanted to be
really careful with this and this is i
think what dr fauci is kind of alluding
to
or or maybe what's being considered by
regulators it was all women 18 to 48
what if you say well maybe you don't
give this vaccine to women 18 to 48.
the other factor and i mentioned this
last week
and there's some early uh suggestions
but it's still being investigated
that there may be um a medicine
interaction
that is common to the individuals that
experience this the six or seven women
that experience the the blood clotting
if it were determined that there's a
specific interaction between a
medication that these women were on and
the vaccine
that would even be further reassuring
you could figure out exactly who it is
that should not receive this vaccine
um and that's something that is
increasingly being looked at
uh there there was a bit of a slowdown
over the weekend
in terms of vaccine doses and in fact
i'm pulling up the numbers myself
although it's not clear that it's
related to the johnson and johnson
um decision if you look at the numbers
from over the weekend there was a bit of
a slowdown in the number of doses given
there are reports that this may be
because of what's called
demand slackening a little bit there was
just a little bit of a downturn if you
go back to about april 11th and look at
the last eight days
the average number of doses has gone
down now
part of it reasonably would be because
of the jnj pause
but there are reports that some states
states where there's
less interest in the vaccine places like
the the example we've been looking at is
mississippi
um there we may actually be at the point
where there is more supply
and ability to give the vaccine then
there is demand and what's going to have
to be figured out is
will vaccines start to be shifted from
states where there is less demand to
states where there is more
demand i believe vermont and
massachusetts both at the top with 92
percent of the population wanting the
vaccine
uh is that even possible is it a recipe
for disaster starting to move vaccines
around
instead will will the focus be just on
uh a campaign to make people want the
vaccine yesterday we saw
um joe biden and barack obama
participate in an event
talking about the vaccine encouraging
people to get it i don't know the answer
but it seems as though
uh today which is the day where
everybody becomes eligible
we are starting to see a slackening of
demand hopefully
full eligibility starting today will
bring a bunch of new demand
and maybe we can get up to even four
million doses a day
remains to be seen jnj though expected
to come back online
possibly as soon as friday one of our
sponsors today
is bluechew a unique online service
delivering
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription
the medication comes straight to your
home within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around
no awkward conversations with your
doctor all of blue chews tablets are
made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping